A Washington Post article,
November,
2016 and it said out of the
700 counties in Pennsylvania,
Ohio,
um,
Wisconsin that voted for Obama twice,
predominantly white counties,
a third of them flipped and
voted for president Trump.
So the racism argument just doesn't
wash because if you vote in a black man
twice for president,
uh,
especially in Ohio,
I think where there was
37 counties that voted,
uh,
predominantly white,
that voted President Obama in twice.
And then they flipped and turned to Ohio.
And I've been raising the red
flag on this for a long time.
I've been saying to people that I really
believe that president Trump's victory,
he's ill equipped to be president.
We all know that.
He has no clue what he's doing was an
absolute a signal that the regressive
left.
This had driven people crazy and insane
and they were frustrated and fed up,
um,
for being called bigoted.
They were sick of being
talked down to and then
still being talked down to like the,
the classic response of
the mainstream media to,
to the existence of Trump is to basically
assume 50% of the American electorate
are stupid racist bigots.
Like Hillary called them deplorables.
The basket of deplorables.
Yeah.
But you know what,
I've been actually kind of looking at
what the grievances are and what the
concerns are and do you sound like
really decent people to me would,
they're asking real questions
about unvetted immigration,
large amounts of
immigration to the country,
border security,
uh,
millions of illegal immigrants.
They're asking very real questions
that would concern anybody and for that
they're being labeled bigoted and racist.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it is in it.
That's the sort of thing that's driving
this dangerous polarization and it's,
it's really,
it's really unfortunate.
Yeah.
And my concern is,
and my concern ever since Trump has been
elected is that we're going to create a
toxic environment in Canada because from
the universities and colleges we can
already see it's there that we are
going to drive people in Canada to very
radical fringe positions.
And that's my worry.
Well,
if we elect wouldn't again then we'll
certainly be well on the road to doing
that.
And I also think that the
Trudeau government is far
to the left of where people
originally assumed it would be.
I mean,
I think that his decision to put 50%
women in the cabinet was an abdication of
responsibility on the magnitude that,
that we haven't seen before
in Canadian political history.
Only 26% of the of the MPs elected
were female and that should have been
approximately the proportion
of cabinet members.
But to say this is 2015 or
whatever the hell the year.
And then to abdicate his responsibility
for selecting the most competent people
was an an indication of exactly how,
uh,
what would you say how suited he is to
be prime minister and people just didn't
make much of an issue of that because
of their attempts to be tolerant.
But I think that what he did was re,
oh,
I thought the fact that he ran to begin
with was reprehensible because he ran
entirely on the name brand recognition
that he had derived from his father.
And I think that that's the mark
of someone who's narcissistic.
You shouldn't have done that
for him.
Very charismatic and attractive,
and he knows how to behave in public.
And so Andy had a very,
very famous name and,
but I believe that it was immoral
of him to run because the,
we're not dynasties,
democracies aren't dynasties,
and he hadn't the,
um,
the CV,
the,
the record of success that you would
need as an independent individual to
justify himself as a qualified
candidate for prime minister.
So I thought that is his candidacy right
from the start was ethically flawed
then to,
to multiply that error with these,
these,
uh,
shallow attempts at
broadcasting tolerance,
especially at the expense of competence
and the capacity to truly evaluate is
just inexcusable.
Inexcusable.